j'aimerais passer au débat de ce club va
évidemment continuer à parler des
collectivités on va parler des cantines
scolaires et j'accueille du coup pour ce
club najat belkacem bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous est vice
président de la fcc la fédération
syndicat des parents d'élèves on a parlé
des cantines scolaires puisque
l'inflation fait augmenter bien
évidemment le coût des repas et donc les
frais pour les collectivités comment
éviter l'impact sur votre porte monnaie
certaines communes trouve des solutions
vers certains maires assument les
hausses on va voir tout ça pendant ce
débat mais d'abord les chiffres pour
tout comprendre et ça c'est avec vous
évidemment elle explosa en cette période
de forte inflation des collectivités
locales ont décidé d'augmenter
eh oui rien on peut dire que déjà la
moitié à des communes augmente le prix
de la cantine scolaire en cette rentrée
une hausse qui évaluée entre 5 et 10%
par l'association des maires de france
alors que le syndicat de la restauration
collective qui fournit les repas dans
les écoles et bien lui demande une
hausse de 7% pour faire face à la hausse
des prix alors qu'est ce qui justifie la
hausse du prix du ticket de cantine
scolaire et bien l'augmentation du coût
des produits alimentaires de l'énergie
est également de la rémunération des
personnels dans les cantines puisque et
bien le gouvernement a décidé
l'augmentation du point d indice de 3 5%
pour les fonctionnaires et donc les
collectivités locales doivent appliquer
cette augmentation par ailleurs noté que
certaines grandes villes ont décidé
d'assumer cette hausse des coûts et donc
de ne pas la répercuter sur les familles
c'est le cas à paris à lyon à marseille
à versailles à toulouse ou encore à
bordeaux mais bien sûr tout le monde ne
peut pas se permettre à près de 100 des
solutions pour éviter que le prix du
ticket de cantine soit trop élevé pour
les familles et en même temps sont
réunis les collectivités et bien la
première solution faire de la
tarification sociale c'est-à-dire
répercuter cette hausse du coût de la
cantine mais seulement sur les familles
qui en ont les moyens par exemple à
lille 45 % des familles seront exemptés
de cette hausse du coût de la cantine
d'autres solutions sont mises en place
dans certaines communes comme le
développement des repas végétariens qui
coûte deux fois moins cher que les repas
avec viande ou poisson c'est ce que fait
par exemple la commune de mouans sartoux
dans les alpes-maritimes et puis une
autre solution est envisagée c'est de
réduire le nombre d'éléments dans les
menus trois au lieu de quatre par
exemple on peut enlever le fromage pour
éviter un peu le gaspillage à la cantine
sans diminuer la qualité nutritive du
repas et comment réagissent les familles
avant de vous entendre évidemment vous
allez nous en parler un et bien pas très
bien ans selon un sondage ifop réalisé
le 27 juillet pour le syndicat national
de la restauration collective et bien 42
% des familles envisagent de supprimer à
certains repas pris à l'école par leur
enfant en cas de trop forte hausse des
tarifs 56 % préfèrent des repas les prix
modérés avec moins de produits bio ou
locaux et puis avec 84 % des parents
sont favorables à ce que les quantités
soient adaptées à chaque élève pour
éviter le gaspillage globalement selon
son sondage et bien trois quarts des
parents sont inquiets par cette hausse
des tarifs de cantine voilà pour les
chiffres le débat est posé on va en
parler avec vous mais d'abord un exemple
c'est lors de notre reportage à votre
rencontre exemple d'une commune qui a
trouvé une solution pour éviter que le
prix augmente pour les parents on va
aller à caudebec les elbeuf c'est en
normandie cent mille repas servi par an
dans les écoles et pour limiter la
hausse du budget ne pas augmenter le
prix du repas la commune supprime chaque
jour soit l'entrée soit le fromage soit
le dessert une sur les champs pour me
parler pas on regarde
dans cette cantine il y à ce jour là un
grand absent au menu les entrées sont
bien là le plat principal aussi comme le
fromage mais le dessert manquent à
l'appel parmi ces maternelle seuls
quelques uns s'en sont rendu compte
parce qu'on n'est pas sache que ses
enfants se rassurent s'il n'y a pas de
dessert ce n'est pas une question de
comportement mais d'économies pour faire
face à l'inflation la mairie de caudebec
les elbeuf près de rouen a choisi
d'enlever un élément du plateau repas
chaque jour on enlève soit l'entrée soit
le fromage soit le dessert alors jamais
le même pour avoir un équilibre en fait
sur la semaine on essaie d'avoir une
proportion de produits laitiers de
fruits et des entrées consistante ou non
selon le plat qu'il ya au jour les
portions imposée par la loi restent les
mêmes mais pour la mairie la facture est
bien différente avec l'augmentation du
prix des matières premières et des
énergies le fournisseur local a dû
augmenter ses tarifs de 7% pour caudebec
les elbeuf c'est 31 mille euros de plus
à payer chaque année inenvisageable pour
cette commune de 10000 habitants avec la
solution de l'élément en moins sur le
plateau le supplément passe de 31 mille
euros à 6000 euros beaucoup plus
raisonnable la mairie peut absorber
cette hausse et ne pas augmenter les
tarifs de la cantine il reste fixé entre
60 centimes et 3 euros 60 selon les
revenus beaucoup d'élèves ne font qu'un
seul repas équilibrés à midi à la
cantine raison de plus pour qu'il vienne
raison de plus pour que ce soit de
qualité équilibré et raison de plus pour
que le tarif de cantine qui est assez
modérée à caudebec reste modérée parce
que si les tarifs deviennent trop cher
les parents ne mettront plus les enfants
à la cantine est donc ce sera autant
d'enfants qui n'auront pas ce repas
équilibré tous les jours à caudebec les
elbeuf 700 enfants sur les 900
scolarisés mangent à la cantine et le
choix de la mairie est plutôt bien
accueillie par les parents alors déjà
qu'on s'en sort pas là en ce moment avec
et course marc si on rajoute en plus le
ticket repas qui augmente ça va être un
peu compliqué à des parents où il on ne
peut pas se permettre parce que si pour
que les enfants rentrent à la maison
sans manger emmène à l'école sans manger
ses 120 vaut mieux garder
le tarif est de façon la quantité et la
qualité reste pareil cela permettrait
aussi de réduire le gaspillage d'après
la mairie 14 tonnes de denrées
alimentaires sont jetés chaque année
dans les cantines de la colline
najat belkacem c'est une bonne solution
trouvée par la mairie les éleveurs pour
vous de supprimer sur l'entrée seul
fromage dessert et du coup de conserver
un prix constant pour les parents alors
conserver le prix constants oui c'est
une bonne solution forcément pour les
familles par contre rogner sur leurs pas
c'est un problème pour nous en fait en
termes éducatifs si vous voulez il avoue
on l'a vu dans le reportage
le petit garçon il a l'impression qu'il
est puni puni le dessert donc forcément
il y aura un impact sur les sur les
enfants et pour nous c'est pas c'est pas
une bonne chose psychologiquement il
faut il faut préserver ce temps qui est
un temps pour nous et éducatif avant
tout c'est une question de santé
publique bien manger ça passe aussi par
la cantine scolaire qui apprend aux
enfants comment se nourrir et dans de
bonnes conditions parce que on s'éteint
c'est un débat qui doit être au niveau
santé puisque les enfants à l'école
apprennent beaucoup de choses et ce
temps scolaire on fait partie c'est
vraiment un temps éducatif
évidemment revenir sur tous âges en
matière pour voir et vous est ce que
toutes les collectivités gèrent leurs
cantines de la même façon non pas du
tout puisqu'on à 60% des des
collectivités qui font appel à des
prestataires extérieurs en connaît
certains noms comme sodexo par exemple
et 40% travail travail en régie parfois
avec des circuits courts parfois avec un
approvisionnement vraiment de de
proximité ce qui permet parfois de de
réduire le choc de de l'inflation donc
les collectivités n'ont pas non plus la
même tarification c'est à dire qu'on
voit par exemple une commune comme
fontenay-sous-bois com communistes en
région parisienne pratiquer les prix de
0 à 6 euros 13 donc là on a une
tarification sociale extrêmement forte
ailleurs c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup
moins c'est beaucoup moins
contrasté donc les hausses varient
vraiment d'une d'une collectivité à une
autre
matériel oui c'est le principe de la
décentralisation oriane
donc effectivement on a une égalité
totale avec des des mairies vous avez
cité marseille qui maintient qui
maintient ses prix mais en même temps
qu'ils augmentent quand même sa taxe
foncière de 14%
il ya des inégalités qui sont dus à des
inégalités face à la hausse des denrées
face à la hausse de l'énergie on a vu
des collectivités faire appel à des
prestataires aussi extérieure pour
l'approvisionnement en électricité c'est
à dire que ces collectivités ne sont
plus aux tarifs réglementés certes les
le prix de l'énergie augmentent parfois
jusqu'à 500% donc pour chauffer les
repas évidemment ça augmente la facture
qui devient qui devient extrêmement
extrêmement salée vous l'avez site et
alexandria la question du du point d
indice qui augmente de 3,2 5% d'autres
certaines collectivités ajoute un coup
de pouce pour déposer agents qui ont
quand même ces derniers ces dernières
années a raconté le gel de gel de leurs
de leur rémunération donc on voit des
prix qui varient dans leur augmentation
très très fortement 1 2 0 % à 25 % on a
des hausses de 25 % dans certaines
villes hélas enfin heureusement parce
que c'est moi un peu nombreuse sages
admet la scène vous les comprenez ses
collègues ses difficultés des
collectivités qui doivent jongler avec
l'inflation est évidemment la hausse des
prix de l'année j'aimerais alimentaires
des personnels qui s'occupe des cantines
puisque c'est à la recharge bien sûr on
les comprend tout à fait parce qu'en
plus les collectivités sous le sigle et
non pas en charge que la cantine
scolaire ils ont en charge tout le pan
du bâti scolaire de du temps
périscolaire donc on comprend que les
budgets des collectivités prennent de
plus en plus de place enfin le budget de
l'école prenne prend de plus en plus de
place dans budget des collectivités nous
ce qu'on demande à la fcpe c'est très
simple c'est que l'état donne un coup de
pouce justement sur cette question là
parce que comme je le disais au début
c'est une question éducative mais c'est
une question si de santé publique et
donc si l'état ne met pas la main à la
poche pour aider les collectivités en
france gestion de crise j'ai envie de
vous dire parce qu'on est en gestion de
crise on va arriver à des situations je
joue mais en parallèle la situation des
piscines actuellement cette semaine on a
on a eu affaire à la fermeture de
certaines piscines due à l'inflation est
justement à la hausse de l'énergie donc
pour les parents si vous voulez ils ne
vont pas pouvoir supporter cette hausse
donc de toutes façons certaines
collectivités ou de voir le répercuter
soit sur un autre budget soit sur les
familles donc au bout du bout ça sera on
en reviendra à la même chose hier que
les parents vont de plus en plus et
c'est le cas de l'enquète les parents
auront de plus en plus ne pas mettre
leurs enfants dans les eaux sur ce temps
de cantine scolaire et le risque c'est
justement qu'on se retrouve avec un un
poste qui devient de plus en plus
importants y compris pour les
collectivités puisque quand les parents
ne mettent pas leurs enfants ne
fréquentent pas les cantines scolaires
forcément ça coûte plus cher aux
collectivités aussi ce sont des retours
que vous avez ça vous avez des parents
qui vous disent mais non on a été
obligés d'enlever nos enfants de la
cantine parce qu'on a pris un moyen payé
la cantine oui on a eu on a eu affaire à
sa notamment pendant la crise qu vide où
les parents en fait
par par souci si vous voulez de gestion
sanitaire enfin de protection sanitaire
de leurs enfants ont retiré leurs
enfants de la cantine et parce qu'en
fait les enfants n'avaient plus le temps
de manger donc je pense que sur une
question budgétaire les familles
forcément vont faire le choix aussi de
trouver d'autres solutions alternatives
soit entre voisins soit voilà pour
éviter justement ponctionner un peu leur
budget parce que leur budget comprend le
transport scolaire on prend les
fournitures scolaires on en a beaucoup
parlé et un tas d'autres choses il faut
pas oublier que les familles supportent
aussi les tarifs du périscolaire donc
pour pouvoir donner accès aussi à des
temps éducatif hors temps scolaire les
familles se privent énormément avec là
aussi des inégalités territoriales et
sociales peut-être entre les parents qui
pourront reprendre leurs enfants à midi
et les faire déjeuner à la maison et
ceux qui ne pourront pas oui on est déjà
sur ce schéma là on a une inégalité
territoriale criante tout à l'heure vous
parliez des tarifs nous on a constaté
des tarifs par menu qui arrivait jusqu'à
13 15 euros c'est énorme enfin je prends
l'exemple d'un adulte quand on va au
restaurant on est à peu près entre 15 et
20 euros quelquefois le menu donc là on
parle de temps éducatif pour des enfants
c'est quand même assez assez
impressionnant les tarifs qu'on peut
trouver un point qui est important
effectivement c'est que le gouvernement
pour le monde demande aux collectivités
de gérer elles seules la charge
l'augmentation de ses prix est ce que
c'est aussi ça le noeud du problème jean
baptiste oui alors le gouvernement a
pratiqué le couac y collant coude
pendant la crise sanitaire dont qu'il
veut pas ouvrir les vannes les vannes
trop vite mais effectivement la cantine
scolaire ça coûte cher en ville au
département aux régions en moyenne ces 9
à 10 euros par part repas et la charge
finalement enfin vous parliez des
parents à juste titre mais la charge est
avant tout supporté par le contribuable
c'est à dire que sur ces 9 à 10 euros la
majeure partie est financée par le
contribuable papale par l'usagé pas
parler pas par les parents et puis un
petit un petit ajout de la de la caf
donc de ce côté là de ce côté là les
collectivités n'ont pas vraiment de de
grain à moudre les dotations ne va vous
ne vont pas augmenter les dépenses de
fonctionnement ont sans doute d'une
manière ou d'une autre être plafonnés on
sait ce qui était dans l'air cet été à
l'assemblée à l'assemblée nationale donc
elles risquent de tirer la langue les
prochaines semaines vous demandez du
convoi
supplémentaires on va parler évidemment
de l'aide demandée par les collectivités
mais une aide supplémentaire du
gouvernement pour les parents comme il
ya une allocation de rentrée par exemple
et ce qui pourrait y avoir une
allocation en devises agi comme ça ça
peut être aussi envisagé sous forme d
aides aux collectivités je veux dire il
ya des solutions pas forcément une aide
directement par un nom va forcément une
aide directement par an il faut juste
que l'état prenne conscience que ce
temps est un temps éducatif que c'est
une question de santé publique et qu'il
faudra à un moment donné ne pas lier si
vous voulez à cette hausse des prix et
les collectivités ne pourront pas tenir
sinon là on le sait un déjà que ça va
être négocié au début d'année il me
sembla le syndicat avait annoncé déjà
une règle renégociation début d'année
nous ce qu'on craint clairement je vous
dis encore une fois c'est que la
fréquentation de la cantine soit
amoindrie et que les familles qui en ont
le plus besoin ne puisse plus envoyer
leurs enfants dans l'est à la cantine et
là ça serait vraiment une catastrophe
sociale parce que c'est vraiment un
temps encore une fois éducatif et
notamment pour les familles les plus
précaires ça s'est passé à beaucoup de
familles assure la cantine c'est le seul
repas finalement ils font exactement
c'est parce que en fait on a beaucoup
d'enfants aussi qui je vous donne
l'exemple par exemple hier c'était la
rentrée une maman m'expliquer que sa
fille est passé de la maternelle au cp
et que la petite s'est trouvé très fier
de porter enfin son plateau d'aller au
self et de choisir ses aliments c'est
tout bête hein mais les enfants c'est
aussi ça leur éduquer fallait éduquer
c'est aussi ça leur apprendra bien
manger et leur apprendre qu'il devienne
adulte à ce moment là est justement alex
parce que avant de vous faire réagir
avec un moule sauf que vous disiez
puisque vous citez tout à l'heure
l'exemple du moins sartoux dans les
alpes maritimes qui privilégie les repas
végétariens puisque la viande et le
poisson est évidemment c'est beaucoup
plus cher ça c'est une solution pour
vous c'est pas une solution c'est peut
être une solution nous en termes
écologiques ça peut être une solution
tout à fait justement parler de la
qualité du repas alors du nombre
d'éléments est-ce qu'il faut enlever le
hommage ou le dessert mais il y aussi et
bien dans le premier quinquennat cette
loi et galim du gouvernement qui impose
et bien dans les établissements de
restauration collective 20 % de produits
bio 50 % de produits locaux on lit dans
la presse régionale que les élus locaux
considèrent que ça aussi c'est un coût
qui est difficilement
acceptable supportable dans cette
période et dans certaines études et bien
les parents sont prêts à rogner sur la
nature de certains aliments c'est pas
grave si ce n'est pas forcément du bio
du moment que c'est un prix acceptable
pour les familles
galim ça a été un problème aussi pour la
cantine scolaire c'est pas été un
problème non habilitées un pur pour que
ce soit mis en place mais la question en
fait de fonds a cessé de se dire on a
avancé sur la question des menus
scolaires est ce qu'aujourd'hui on doit
régresser pour des questions financières
c'est surtout ça la question donc l'état
doit prendre la mesure de ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui il ya eu des avancées
est-ce qu'on va rogner sur ses avancées
pour des questions budgétaires aussi
simple que ça et aujourd'hui l'état doit
trouver des solutions parce que ce n'est
pas aux parents de trouver des solutions
je pense que le lien entre l'état et les
collectivités doit être beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus serré pour pouvoir
discuter de ces questions là qui sont
des anges ou encore une fois ce aussitôt
de santé là on a vu l'exemple de
caudebec les elbeuf en normandie on le
maire a fait le choix de supprimer une
des composantes d'un repas pour ne pas
augmenter le prix du ticket mais il ya
certains maires qui assume d'augmenter
les tarifs et c'est votre cas jean
pierre barrau merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous vous êtes le maire de chaudière sur
marne c'est dans le val de marne
pourquoi avoir augmenté les tarifs on
imagine que vous n'aviez pas d'autre
choix
oui mais je reprends ce qui a été dit
par madame la vice présidente de la fcpe
les collectivités ont subi au fil des
années une érosion grands moyens si je
prends l'exemple de ma commune sur deux
millions celle de dotation il reste
l'udc 600000 euros
dans le même temps à chennevières nous
avons décidé pour
contrer le réchauffement climatique de
refaire de reconstruire une nouvelle
école de
de rendre
[Musique]
donné de restaurer une autre notamment
sur le plan thermique et au total on a
consacré pour les écoles
45 millions d'euros on va consacrer sur
les demandes à 45 millions d'euros ça
veut dire une anémie du budget cléry
donc c'est un effort considérable
dans le même temps si vous voulez notre
tarif n'avait pas évolué depuis 2010 est
et on a mis en place une nouvelle
méthode de tarification qui
possèdent des taux d'effort c'est à dire
entre un plancher et un plafond et
certains parents voient leur facture
diminuer donc c'est c'est plutôt et ça
permet d'adapter le tarif sont revenus
sur l'année est moins face heureux sur
les game was avec même des possibilités
de correction et pour les tarifs plus
bas nous avons modifié notre politique
de soutien dans le cadre du ccas pour
l'ouvrir davantage aux familles donc on
a bien conscience que c'est un effort
pour demande mais c'était fort une
contrepartie c'est d'une part le
maintien d'une politique très ambitieuse
d'investissements parce que je crois
qu'on ne peut pas passer son temps à
vouloir lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique et puis avoir des écoles qui
sont des passoires thermiques et pour le
moment quand on dit qu'il faudrait un
soutien financier aux collectivités
c'est cool inverse qui se produit non
seulement il n'y a pas de soutien mais
il ya une diminution des moyens qui sont
accordées aux collectivités est en
quelque sorte et les collectivités
devraient être la variable d'ajustement
c'est à dire que le jeu concernant les
les le quotient familial des allocations
familiales
un certain nombre de familles pas l'émoi
des papas les moins favorisés mais se
sont trouvé
écarté ses prestations et c'est en
quelque sorte la collectivité qui
devrait qui devrait s
faire la politique sociale et familiale
que vous fait pas c'est pas possible un
mot d'autant que les collectivités comme
les entreprises ne bénéficient pas du
bouclier tarifaire dont
beaucoup de choses jean pierre barou
dans ce que vous nous dites on va y
revenir d'abord non mais d'abord sur
l'augmentation parce que je vais laisser
vous répondre
najat belkacem mon l'augmentation vous
entendez ce maire elle a été nécessaire
et en même temps il a dû investir
notamment toujours sur cette question de
l'école mais dans d'autres domaines vous
comprenez ça oui c'est ce que je disais
au début on sait très bien aujourd'hui
les collectivités supporte beaucoup de
budget de l'école et il ya le temps
périscolaire il ya le bâti scolaire le
bâti scolaire comme disait monsieur
c'est un sujet à lui tout seul on l'a vu
pendant la crise sanitaire et
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
d'investissement massif dans le bc
bâtiments scolaires en fait on a demandé
nous au ministère de de vraiment prévoir
un plan sur le bâti scolaire parce que
ça aussi non seulement il ya la question
thermique mais pas que cela il ya la
question sanitaire aussi la crise est
passée par là on devrait en tirer des
conséquences or aujourd'hui on se rend
compte que finalement les conséquences
ne ne sont pas tirées de cette crise
elles ne sont pas non plus sur la
question de l'inflation est aujourd'hui
l'état doit prendre ses responsabilités
en effet là dessus si vous posez la
question à moi en tant que parents et je
vous dis l'école normalement l'école
républicaine est gratuite aujourd'hui
l'école républicaine n'est pas gratuite
donc c'est ça pose souci quand même
d'accord ça on imagine
jean pierre vernant
oui je suis d'accord et
bien entendu où nous nous avons souhaité
si vous voulez ne pas réduire les
prestations à côté des des prestations
restauration il ya beaucoup de sorties y
compris pour les pour les jeunes de
milieux défavorisés des toute une série
de prestations incertain la jeunesse
notre politique y compris pour la
qualité de la restauration a été de ne
pas réduire et de continuer je veux dire
que 45 millions dé forces sur deux
mandatures pour le baptise polaire c'est
considérable parce qu'on a dans le
thunder avait que des écoles en mauvais
état en particulier deux de peu de ces
écoles donc on a voulu continuer cet
effort alors est ce que la concertation
qu'on va entreprendre au fil de l'année
avec les parents nous produira à réduire
certains déplacements je ne sais pas
mais pour le moment on dit rester dans
nos objectifs de départ ça a été notre
choix
de défendre encore comparaître demandé
aux parents
n'ont pas d'enfant financiers je crois
qu'il ya une limite mais même si les
tarifs sociaux et sont à deux jours ou
apps avec avec une possibilité aussi des
travaux sur du ccs donc on n'est pas
pour les tarifs les plus sociaux dans
une situation plus extraordinaire par
rapport à beaucoup d'autres communes les
efforts qui pourraient effet j'entends
que ont réduit les composants mené à
cinq composantes on pourrait peut-être
passé un quart en fonction d'une analyse
du gaspillage alimentaire
parce que là j'entends des cons passer
de quatre à trois mois de 4 à 3 je ne
suis pas falloir parce que effectivement
notre reportage montre des enfants qui
n'ont pas l'air
il se reproche en quelque sorte que la
prestation donc ça je ne le souhaite pas
on peut imaginer qu'un certain manque de
centimes enfin parce que aujourd'hui
les des commandes de car les tarifs sont
au jour le jour en fonction de
l'évolution du prix de l'essence ou de
prix du gaz du fioul ou de gasoil
oui on trempe d'un compte finalement que
le sujet est très complexe et que vous
faites au mieux et que c'est évidemment
compliqué merci jean pierre barnaud
d'avoir été avec nous maires de
chennevières sur marne dans le val de
marne la conclusion rapidement de cet
élevage en batterie juste un mot sur une
variable d'ajustement qui pourrait être
le passage au repas végétarien on a vu
le le maire de grenoble tenter sa chance
pour des raisons écologiques idéologique
dirai peut-être certains ça a été un
bide complet dire que plus de 90 % des
parents ou dit non au repas végétariens
tous les jours à grenoble voilà ce sera
loin de la fin merci beaucoup d'habileté
vous restez encore avec nos évidemment à
vos passions
[Musique]